okay so listen we haven't done this for
a while and the reason we haven't done
this for a while is not because we lost
our Amazon affiliate link I used to
recommend books and nonfiction and
fiction books on the show and I would
say if you buy them through our amazon
link we get a little kickback and as I
told people close to a year ago at this
point we lost our Amazon affiliate link
as many progressive and conservative
shows have because really we weren't
exactly using those links the way that
the Terms of Service say that you should
and a few people emailed and say David
are you no longer recommending books
because you lost your Amazon link and
the answer is no I haven't been
recommending books because we've been so
busy with political stories but I do get
emails from people saying give us a
sense of what you've been reading
because you sometimes had good
recommendation I thought it was just
because you stopped reading no no but
apparently not I've been reading a ton
okay so I'm gonna take a minute here to
give you a bunch of recent fiction and
nonfiction books that I read Pat's gonna
take very very close notes cuz he does
also sometimes read and people in the
audience are maybe going to enjoy this
fiction okay
new fiction literature the Knicks by
Nathan Hill that's n IX very long but
700 pages fantastic new novel the Knicks
by nathan hill couldn't recommend it
more highly the Great North Road by
Peter F Hamilton this is a sci-fi book
ok the Knicks is not sci-fi it's I guess
I guess you would call it literary
fiction the Great North Road by Peter F
Hamilton sci-fi book nine hundred pages
long oh it is it is a big book but it is
not a slog it's actually really really
great highly highly recommend that to
you I've also been reading more eric
ambler books eric ambler was the
inspiration to one of my favorite
fiction authors john lecarre a and i've
read a couple more eric ambler books any
of his books are really good and I also
read John Laker as new one a legacy of
spies he is in his 80s now and he still
continues to put out a really good book
like every three years so those are my
fiction recommendations anything in
there pat that tickles your fancy or do
those not sound like books that you
would be interested it's not much of a
fiction guy as of late oh boy yeah I
hope you're not expecting like a book
report no no no okay we'll cut that calm
down from the final version nonfiction
okay nonfiction stuff I've read recently
a very short introduction I really like
that series the very short introductions
I read the one on decision-making and
problem solving very very good highly
recommend it I read the book flim-flam
by James Randi where he exposes a ton of
different pseudoscience and it connects
to an upcoming miniseries we're gonna be
doing on the program Carl Sagan's very
famous book the demon haunted world
science as a candle in the dark
excellent book and I'm also reading a
Peter Drucker the famed management
consultants book the effective
executives from 1964 or so and it really
seems dated only in that the idea that
there might be a female executive is
totally missing from the book it's only
hehehe the the concept that you might
have a female CEO just doesn't even
enter into Peter Drucker Peter Drucker's
mind as the book is written but it's a
really really good book in a lot of ways
so some of the fiction I've been reading
some of the nonfiction I've been reading
and I recommend it to you with total
peace and love because we don't have our
Amazon link anymore and we can't make
money off of you buying these books so
check those out
tweet me at de Pakman if you've read any
of these we'll take a break and be back
after this